it's the most interesting thing i saw
this week the new york times
commissioned a pair of focus groups one
with democrats one with republicans
to find out their attitudes to the state
of our democracy january the 6th all of
that
and it turns out they were surprised by
what the democrats said because it ran
completely counter to the entire
narrative that's been pushed for the
last year by the new york times by all
the rest of the establishment medium by
democrat politicians here's what they
said about the capital right and as you
listen remember these are democrat
voters saying this quote it's an
inevitable boiling point of flawed
systems that were put into place and
have only gotten worse over the years
the enemy is the system that needs
either a complete makeover or severe
reform in order to protect the
livelihoods of the people not the rich
oh
not an attempted coup then an
insurrection here's another democrat
quote i think it was the frustration of
the american people people are fed up
with politics telling you lies
we heard a lot about the big lie this
week
but as that democrat voter said the
reason so many americans are frustrated
and angry is because the people in
charge just seem like a bunch of big
liars
they lie shamelessly all the time
they lie about the pandemic fauchi lying
about the reckless experiments he
commissioned they're at the most likely
origin of the pandemic the rest of the
media may have moved on but we will not
rest until fauci is held accountable for
what he did
they lied about masks telling us all to
wear them when they knew cloth masks
couldn't stop an airborne virus
they lied about lockdowns they lied
about social distancing about testing
about the vaccines and now they wonder
why nobody trusts a word the public
health experts say about anything
they told us that defunding and
demoralizing the police wouldn't lead to
higher crime that was a lie
they lied about individual crimes the
evil suv that murdered six people in
that christmas parade jossey smollett
kyle rittenhouse the covington kid
anti-agent hate portrayed as white
supremacy even when carried out by black
attackers
they lied they continue to lie about
biden family corruption in fact they
don't just lie they censor the truth
they lie about the economy they said
spending trillions of dollars wouldn't
fuel inflation and now look
they said the supply chain crisis was
just rich people worrying about their
treadmills
they lie incessantly about their climate
crisis
they pretend we can hit their carbon
targets without natural gas and nuclear
power they endlessly push solar panels
wind farms electric cars when a recent
report said electric cars quote will not
significantly reduce carbon dioxide
output only shift its location
they lied about russia they lied about
china and of course they lied non-stop
about their humiliating catastrophe in
afghanistan on and on it goes lie after
lie after line yes these are lies
they're not mistakes or differences of
opinion they know the things they're
saying are false but they say them
anyway
and the most destructive divisive
example paraded before us this week
are you going to be a nation that lives
not by the light of the truth
but in the shadow
of lies right now
in state after state
new laws are being written
not to protect the vote
but to deny it
not only to suppress the vote but to
subvert it
the shadow of lies what he said is a lie
the changes he's talking about are
designed to clean up the mess of the
pandemic voting rules in most cases they
actually make it easier to vote than
before the pandemic
but biden's lie
gets to the heart of the entire cynical
spectacle the washington establishment
put on for us this week all of it had a
partisan political purpose
why are the democrats after an election
in which more people voted than ever
before in history hysterically screaming
hyped up nonsense about our democracy
being under attack
to try and justify their own efforts to
rig elections in their favor with
corrupt banana republic atrocities like
ballot harvesting
why did liz cheney say this to our
friend brett bear
what's the ultimate goal of the january
6th committee
we have several goals one is obviously
the legislative purpose
that i've mentioned the extent to which
there may be legislation
or enhanced penalties for example that
we need to look at to make sure this
never happens again
she knows
what the congressional rules say that
there's no legitimacy to the january 6
committee unless it has a legislative
purpose but what potential legislation
is she burbling on about of course the
whole thing is about stopping trump by
trying to prove he organized an
insurrection
but i just read michael wolff's book
about the election and its aftermath
hardly a pro-trump account it's
absolutely clear far from coordinating
the riot trump was almost entirely
focused on what was going on inside the
capital what mike pence would do and
even that was not exactly some evil
genius scheme to overturn the election
apparently john eastman the lawyer who
persuaded trump that the vice president
could send the votes back to the states
he didn't even believe in what he was
saying himself
obviously the establishment are
exploiting january the sixth to try and
destroy trump his movement and his ideas
but who do they think wants to go back
to the establishment gop and it's open
borders endless war suck up to china the
rich get richer and american workers get
screwed trump's populism is popular
it's why the republican party is
becoming a multi-racial working-class
coalition and it's why we need to tell
the truth to ourselves too that you're
not going to win the next election by
whining about the last one let the
establishment obsess about all that they
look ridiculous
now we're supposed to take the cheney
seriously as the defenders of our
democracy that cheney's
liz who inherited her seat in congress
like some pampered aristocrat dick
who sent other people's children to war
on a lie
wars that shoveled billions of dollars
into the bank account of halliburton the
defense contractor he used to run
the cheneys have to be among the most
corrupt anti-democratic families in
modern american history
but they're in good company with their
new pals on the left what nauseating
hypocrisy from kamla harris nancy pelosi
and all the rest this week what
laughable but also despicable
histrionics comparing the capital right
to pearl harbor and 911 from the exact
same people who reveled in the
destruction and mayhem of the summer
rights in 2020
the truth is
only one of america's major parties
today supports political violence
and that's the democrats
they're not going to stop and and
everyone beware because they're not
going to stop everyone should take note
of that on both levels that this isn't
they're not going to let up and they
should not and we should not throwing it
into the harlem people
there needs to be unrest in the streets
for as long as there is unrest in our
lives
they only care about riots when it hits
their place of work these sanctimonious
self-righteous charlatans biden harris
pelosi have never started a business or
created a job in their corrupt lives
they couldn't give a crap about
someone's small business being burnt to
the ground i don't remember their
grandiose speeches honoring the dozens
who lost their lives at the hands of the
left-wing mob
every decent american will look upon
them with complete contempt
and so this is how we enter 2022 with a
political establishment utterly mired in
lies hypocrisy and incompetence the
pitiful symbol of it all the bumbling
fool in the white house
there's a lot of reason to be hopeful in
2020
but for god's sake
please take advantage of what's
available
just look at him
he looks half dead
slurring his words
can't remember what year it is
can we really put up with three more
years of this
and on this point there was actually
some honesty on display this week and
amazingly enough it came from a democrat
he is the head of a progressive
political group aoc's former
communications director talking about
biden
he's deeply unpopular he's old as well
it starts with s and ends in hit
he's largely been in fact ineffective
and i think he'll probably get
demolished in the midterms and that's
from a democrat you see just as we saw
at the start many democrats aren't
buying the bs of their leaders
as that member of the new york times
focus group said people have lost faith
in the entire system and they're right
you can't trust the politicians you
can't trust the bureaucrats you can't
trust the technocrats you can't trust
the experts you can't trust the media
you certainly can't trust big tech so in
the face of all this we come back to the
idea that is at the heart of this show
trust the people
positive populism put power in people's
hands
and they will use it wisely that's the
next revolution we need
tell us what you think at steve hilton x
and at next rev fnc and share this
message hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else